la navette américaine challenger explose
en plein ciel il y avait sept
astronautes à bord il n'y a pas de
survivant
la sixième chaîne de télévision
française verra le jour avant la fin du
mois de février
c'est le projet comme mon publicis
énergie qui l'a emporté elle sera
essentiellement musicale madame monsieur
bonsoir ce devait être la routine ce fut
le drame 45 secondes après le décollage
la navette américaine challenger
exploser en plein vol lc pulvérisé dans
une gerbe de flammes
il y avait sept astronautes à bord selon
la nasa il n'y a pas de survivant avant
de revenir sur les détails sur les
explications de cette catastrophe
tout de suite les images de l'accident
et des secondes qui l'ont précédé avec
hervé brusini il avait fait très froid
ici à cap canaveral sens dans la nuit ce
petit matin le pas de tir était en
partie gelé deux heures de retard pour
le lancement 11h38 heure locale 13h38
17h38 pardon chez nous le décompte
commence
nous sommes à 25 secondes du départ est
tout est normal
quinze secondes du départ système de
pression lourds enclenchèrent net en
mode automatique les ordinateurs
interroge 440 fois par seconde et
moteurs à l'image du moteur principal
à l'image des deux fusées les booster
qui sont part et d'autre de l'énorme
réservoir c'est le décollage super à
terre ils sont admiratifs trêve
rapidement la navette atteint les 3 4
kilomètres par seconde
et puis vient la réduction progressive
de la puissance 94% 84% coût 65 la
navette va pivoter sur elle-même et tout
est parfaitement normal comment que le
patron du centre de la nasa
bientôt les caméras du sol vont quitter
la navette la prise de vue va être
relayée par avion mais soudain
la navette totalement pulvérisées
une partie du public donne confiance
l'une des deux fusées d'appoint continue
une course désormais folle mais comment
tout cela s'est il réellement passé
revoyons les images des flammèches
apparaissent à la base de notre
principal et puis très vite tout a
explosé ce soir à cap canaveral pour le
moment la consternation prend encore le
pas sur la volonté de comprendre
voilà donc pour les images nous allons
bien sûr consacré une grande partie de
ce journal à cet accident la navette
américaine qui a donc explosé dans le
ciel de floride est tout de suite bien
des questions que l'on se pose ce soir
avec vous patrick esther qui connaît
bien la région qui connaissez bien la
navette est la première question il eut
deux reports successifs
est ce qu'on aurait fait lens -
conséquent n'ont en aucun cas on ne peut
dire ça la nasa n'a jamais pris l'ombre
d'un risque s'il y avait eu le moindre
doute sur ce tir la navette n'aurait pas
décollé les deux reports successifs
étaient dus à des problèmes tout à fait
marginaux annexes en principe en tout
cas on attendu que de la glace fonde sur
certaines parties la navette dû au
mauvais temps
et puis surtout à la compression d
oxygène et d hydrogène qu'on glisse à
l'intérieur de cet énorme réservoir qui
précisément est probablement à l'origine
de la catastrophe aucun risque c'est
certain quand la navette a décollé
personne ne pouvait prévoir qui est
l'ombre de un tout petit problème ma
patrie vous connaissez bien cap
canaveral vous connaissez bien la
navette est ce qu'on peut imaginer ou
expliquer ce soir ce qui s'est passé
précisément vous savez berne en moi j'ai
souvent assisté au décollage la navette
et je dois dire qu assez souvent je me
suis demandé ce que ce qui se passerait
si effectivement cette bombe
cette bombe exploserait parce que parce
que ces véritables une bombe la navette
je veux dire comme toutes les fusées
c'est des carburants des des centaines
de tonnes de carburant à l'intérieur ici
de ce réservoir pain en marron vous avez
700 tonnes 700 tonnes d'oxygène et
d'hydrogène liquide on a tous fait
l'expérience que j'avais avec un
demi-gramme d'oxygène et d'hydrogène
dans une salle de classe
on a vu l'explosion que ça donne vous
imaginez tout de suite ce que ça peut
faire une bombe dont on peut comparer
l'important souhaite avec une petite
bombe atomique et où il faut bien le
dire
alors là je vous propose de regarder ce
qui s'est produit exactement sur les
images très très très en détail les
images au ralenti
oui j'ai eu au téléphone tout à l'heure
aux jeunes sert dame qui était un
astronaute de la nasa et qui m'a bien
confirmé qu'il semblerait que
l'accident soit arrivé à l'intérieur de
ce réservoir dans le bas du réservoir
vous voyez des petites flammes s sortir
des grosses flammes et puis d'un seul
coup une explosion violente à peu près à
l'endroit qui sépare l'oxygène de
l'hydrogène
et puis d'un seul coup l'orbiteur la
navette elle même qui qui part en
miettes et vous voyez sur les côtés ici
des petits débris là un objet qui sort
c'est le gros boosters à poudre une
fusée latéral qui continue sa course
tout à fait folle tout à fait
incontrôlable bien sûr et puis tout à
l'heure on a vu un petit parachute
s'ouvrir ce parachute c'est celui qui
permet de récupérer ces fusées à poudre
il est bien évident que les sommes
n'avaient pas de parer à un moment non
non tout de suite tout de suite c'était
évident quand on a vu cette explosion
juste au dos il voulait de delà de la
navette
il était impossible pratiquement qui
assure yvan et même s'il y avait eu des
parachutes y avait des choses pour eux
ça on pouvait rien faire contre les
preuves que la température atteint tout
de suite plusieurs centaines de degrés
en quelques milliardièmes de seconde
oui d'après donc que les dernières
communications internes ou échangés
entre l'équipage et le centre de
contrôle et bien ils se sont aperçus de
rien ça s'est passé très très vite
effectivement puisque en quelques
secondes c'était donc terminée 45
secondes donc après le décollage cette
gigantesque boule de feu
vous avez vu qui c'était aller dans le
ciel au dessus de cap canaveral il y
avait donc sept personnes à bord de
l'engin c'est l'équipage habituel des
navettes américaines
parmi eux il y avait deux femmes tout au
long de ces derniers jours les
téléspectateurs américains avaient pu
suivre leur préparation la prépare sur
l'équipage leur mise en condition pour
ce qui est de semblait devoir être une
mission presque banal tant la conquête
de l'espace fait dorénavant partie de
notre vie quotidienne l'une de ces
femmes d'ailleurs une institutrice tu
avais d'ailleurs pour mission de
démystifier les voyages dans l'espace
puisqu'il n'était pas astronautes ni
schwartz en embarquant pour la troisième
fois en deux jours vers le pas de tir
deux challengers les sept astronautes de
la 25ème mission d'une navette spatiale
n'avait pas vraiment de raison de perdre
leur sourire
la composition de l'équipage et des
symboliques il comprenait aussi bien les
habitués que des néophytes des hommes
que des femmes
et il était multiraciale à leur tête le
commandant dicks kobe qui avait déjà
volé en 1984 avec lui jeudi 13 nick 36
ans l'une des deux femmes de la mission
ellison onizuka l'un des deux américains
deux couleurs de cette même mission
grégory dziwisz à l'ingénieur de la
société youg's aircraft ronald mac nerfs
un chercheur spécialisé dans les lasers
michael semé le copilote l'adjoint donc
du commandant korbi et enfin christa
mcauliffe 37 ans la première citoyenne
privé à voler dans l'espace
cette enseignante avait subi pendant
plusieurs mois un entraînement intensif
et tout cela dans un seul but donnait à
partir de l'espace des cours de physique
élémentaire à des élèves restés à terre
dans la ville où elle enseignait elle
était considérée comme une héroïne à
l'égal des gloires les plus célèbres ses
concitoyens garderont d'elle l'image
paisible d'une mère de famille comme
n'importe quelle mère de famille
américaine
oui puis donc 45 secondes après le
décollage cet accident l'exploser la
navette donc il ya sept morts alors la
preuve quand même que ce n'est pas un
voyage tout à fait banal comme voulait
le prouver cette femme cette attitude le
stratège christa mcauliffe en fait tu
partais à bord de la navette comme plus
tard ou penser envoyer des journalistes
envoyés c'était la première citoyenne
américaine a monté à bord sans avoir
reçu un entraînement particulier
on voulait faire la preuve que cette
navette était véritablement un objet
fabuleuse qui demandait qui qu'ils
allaient vulgariser le voyage spatial on
s'aperçoit que la conquête de l'espace
c'est quand même pas si simple que ça
même quand on dispose de gros moyens
et puis j'aurais préciser quand même là
ici une petite précision qui me parvient
c'est que on a vu la navette au début de
son vol basculer sur le dos comme ceci
en fait elle allait se diriger vers la
bonne orbite est du reste le speaker
officiel de la nasa a précisé
elle est sur le bon chemin et puis c'est
à ce moment là que s'est produit
l'incident et or il faut savoir que
pendant un moment où la navette bascule
on réduit la puissance des gros moteurs
à oxygène et hydrogène précisément à peu
près à 65% de leur puissance
elle bascule et quand elle a fini de
basculer à sont là on remet plein gaz on
en voit toute la gomme et c'est
semble-t-il ce moment là que le
réservoir a explosé peut-être des
problèmes de deux structures à
l'intérieur peut être des problèmes de
chargement en carburant bien c'est bien
sûr la stupeur vous l'imaginez la
stupeur dans le monde entier notamment
aux états unis où le tir de challenger
et donc le drame
filmez vous l'avez vu en direct par les
télévisions c'est bien sûr la
consternation pour tout le monde
cela va des simple spectateur ou
téléspectateur qui ont donc assisté au
lancement jusqu'aux hommes politiques à
commencer par le président reagan nous
retrouvons en direct au téléphone avec
nous notre correspondant à washington
jacquat bouchard est d'abord bien sûr le
climat
jacques à mouchin découvert les images
qui s'était passé la tragédie du cap
canaveral
il a immédiatement décidé floride avec
le directeur de la neuve pour essayer de
recueillir les presser les premiers
éléments une enquête
votre décision de monsieur regan qui
devait normalement prenant cette foire
sans message sur l'état kenyan et
constitue entendu de l'activité du
gouvernement
le président a décidé 2 avril d'ailleurs
cette déclaration à la nation américaine
aujourd'hui c'est à noter notamment cet
enseignant jacques bouchard je suppose
que les télévisions aux états unis ont
cessé leurs émissions en tout cas ne
parle que de cela qui ont suivi la
tragédie canaveral
l'émission était un terrain peu tous les
réseaux de télévision ont commencé à
augmenter essentiellement de ce qui s'y
passe et 2 passes et en floride
et c'est une les commentaires les
commentaires sans a priori nature a pris
depuis depuis ce matin depuis de pompey
a eu lieu la tragédie n'est question que
de la question que de fait quatre fois
ci encore une fois en amérique mais
précisément une réaction en france cette
fois une réaction donc avec un
télégramme du président de la république
monsieur mitterrand qui écrit tout à
l'heure à ronald reagan
la dépêche marival instant il a fait
état de la profonde émotion des français
devant l'explosion de la navette
challenger et de la disparition de son
équipage il ajoute que cela a toujours
été le destin des peuples courageux
c'est ce que dit monsieur mitterrand
découvreur de monde nouveau que de payer
ainsi un lourd tribut aux progrès mais
nous savons que rien ajoute le président
que rien ne décourage d'humanité dans sa
marche en avant alors je pense que dans
un tout petit instant nous serons en
liaison directe avec patrick baudry qui
est en quête à bordeaux et qui a
participé à l'une des missions de la
navette américaine c'était il ya
quelques mois il pourra nous dire
également ce qu'il pense et peut-être
nous apporter des précisions sur
l'accident lui-même sur les raisons donc
de cette catastrophe
il faut ajouter à tout cela patrick
esther que ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'un accident se produit ainsi depuis
qu'il commençait la conquête de l'espace
du côté américain
une catastrophe du même type s'était
produite lors d'une mission apollo oui
c'était le 27 janvier 1967 c'était à
bord d'une capsule apollo l'une des
toutes premières qui se trouvait sur son
pas de tir à cap carlier à cap kennedy
et là les astros n'avait même pas
décollé à la suite d'un petit court
circuit qui s'étaient produits sous leur
siège et bien les trois hommes avaient
brûlé sans même que le centre de
contrôle au sol se rendent compte qu'ils
se passe qui se veut qu'il se passait
quelque chose à bord de la capsule à la
suite de cet accident la cave est
vraiment fortement marqué déjà
l'amérique est bien la nasa avait décidé
de revoir absolument tout le programme
on avait toujours vérifié on s'était
aperçu que un tout petit boulon parfois
mal serré dans un petit coin c'était un
truc qu'on pouvait laisser passer c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut laisser passer
mais que ça pouvait avoir des
conséquences dramatiques
et à cette époque là on avait revu
absolument tout la fusée saturn 5 un
monstre 3500 tonnes
but à l'autre alors il faut dire que ça
c'était le premier accident à bord
c'était crimson et dwight et et robert
jaffe
mais quelques mois plus tard le premier
soviétique vladimir komarov s'était
écrasé lui à bord d'un soyouz
un soyouz qui au moment de rentrer sur
terre avait vu ses parachutes il y avait
trois parachutes se prendre encore
sembler les uns les autres et l'homme
était mort écrasé et puis le 29 juin 71
à nouveau trois morts trois soviétique
qui au moment de la rentrée dans
l'atmosphère
lorsque le vaisseau s'était séparé entre
la capsule de rentrée et puis le module
orbital si vous voulez qu'ils restent
dans l'espace et bien l'appareil avait
connu une perte de décompression et les
trois hommes étaient morts asphyxiés
la capsule s'était posée en douceur mais
les trois hommes étaient morts quand on
avait ouvert la capsule avec nous
maintenant direct je pense patrick
baudry qui est à bordeaux
patrick baudry n'avons pas la liaison
apparemment oui bonsoir je l'entends je
vous entends je ne vois pas là vous êtes
là croyez-moi c'est le baudrier merci
d'être là que vous étiez l'un des
passagers lors d'une précédente mission
sur la navette américaine
alors ma première question c'est est ce
qu'on pense d'abord que cela peut
arriver lorsque l'on décolle ainsi est
ce qu'on ne pense pas plutôt que toutes
les mesures de sécurité ont son prêt que
ça ne peut pas se passer comme ça c'est
quand même vécu des factions un peu
partout dans le monde ce soir
oui bien sûr vous savez la navette
américaine c'est un engin extraordinaire
et extrêmement complexe est réellement
là une machine très imposante et lorsque
vous installer à bord vous avez une
grande confiance dans cette machine
prenez-en très simple c'est que elle est
avant tout le fruit d'un du travail de
l'équipe très nombreuses de gens très
nombreux qui sont complètement
professionnel très sérieux et
normalement rien ne passe comme l'a dit
patrick esther tout à l'heure
normalement rien ne passe donc il n'y a
pas eu d'actes prudents sur ce lancement
est votre avis
je suis persuadé qu'il n'y a eu
absolument aucune imprudence la cause
exacte de l'accident
juniors encore il faut attendre les
résultats de l'enquêté de la nasa bien
sûr mais je suis absolument persuadé
qu'il n'y a eu aucune imprudence de la
part de la nasa je peux vous garantir
que non seulement pendant tout
l'entraînement mais lorsque l'on est sur
le point d'être d'être tirées de partir
et
je suis bien placé pour le savoir que
j'ai vu de nombreux reports de tir à
cause de petits incidents techniques
vraiment la nasa ne prend aucun risque
et toutes les équipes de la nasa sont là
vous avez des centaines de gens qui
travaillent jour et nuit les jours qui
précèdent un qui précède un lancement
est réellement
il n'y a pas de routine on parle souvent
de routine à propos des vols spatiaux
notamment des walt navette je peux vous
dire qu'il n'ya pas encore de routine
c'est réellement un travail extrêmement
délicat très très difficile et chacun
chaque chaque techniciens de la nasa
chaque ingénieur à chacun ce trop notre
bien sûr se concentre complètement sur
sa tâche les jours qui précèdent un tir
et patrick baudry patrick à strasbourg à
vous poser une question patrick baudry
je ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez un
matin nous étions à houston vettier
l'intérieur du simulateur de vol de la
navette et vous en fils y ait un gros
casque qui devait en principe vous
isoler totalement au moment où la
navette décoller est ce que vous pensez
véritablement que ces systèmes suffisent
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
véritablement protéger les hommes au
moment du décollage pareil la navette
est un véhicule d'un type nouveau à bord
duquel donc le l'intégrité de l'engin
seyant l'intégrité de la navette elle
même doit être respectée c'est à dire
que les hommes qui se trouvent à bord
peuvent revenir sur terre à bord du
véhicule ce n'est pas comme les anciens
systèmes apollo ou l'actuel système
soviétique où il ya un système
d'éjection qui fait que en cas
d'incidents semblables pouvait être
éjectée et être séparé du véhicule comme
à l'aide d'un siège éjectable sur un
avion
la navette elle sa fiabilité repose
avant tout sur le contrôle de très très
nombreux paramètres qui sont permis par
la puissance de
des ordinateurs de bord est réellement
tout est envisagé donc il ne doit pas y
avoir de problème d'autant plus que
pendant les deux premières minutes du
tir quand on est encore accrochée aux
deux boosters latéraux que vous avez vu
sur les images vous n'avez pas de
recours c'est à dire il faut absolument
que ces boosters arrivent au bout de
leur combustion sans qu'il y ait de
problème car là vous ne pouvez pas vous
savez que vous pouvez lire
entrée 5 / / maison pas d'issue il n'y a
pas d'issue beaudry merci merci pour ces
précisions nous aurons l'occasion de
reparler tout cela bien sûr il faut un
petit peu avant c'est parce que le
journal tourne aussi c'est en tout cas
ce qu'on pouvait dire ce soir quelques
heures après l'explosion donc de cette
navette américaine challenger c'était en
fin d'après-midi tout à l'heure l'engin
venait de décoller sur son pas de tir à
cap canaveral 45 secondes plus tard
c'était donc le drame la navette se
transforme en une véritable boule de feu
elle se désintègre en plein ciel il y
avait sept astronautes à bord qu'il n'ya
pas survivants bien sûr nous avons
d'autres détails d'autres précisions
nous y reviendrons d'ici à la fin de ce
journal
il nous faut d'abord poursuivre le tour
d'horizon de l'actualité avec l'autre
grande information de ce mardi c'est à
dire le coup d'envoi de la sixième
chaîne de télévision française n'a pas
encore de nous n'appellerons donc la six
mais on sait déjà ce soir qu'elle sera
mise en oeuvre par un groupe qui associe
les films goom publicis l' agence de
publicité gilbert groulx et la radio
privée énergie la sixième chaîne
seraient essentiellement musicale elle
devrait commencer à nourrir nos postes
de télévision avant la fin du mois
prochain sa fiche d'identité maintenant
par gaëlle monde a eu qu une chaîne
musicale c'est à dire 50 % de programmes
musicaux des clips et concerts mais
aussi des films et des séries sans vidéo
clip produit par la chaîne dès la
première année
dix heures de programmes par jour
dès la mi-février peut-être même avant
la cinquième chaîne une chaîne très
ciblée sur les 12 35 ans tout pour les
jeunes avec un ton différent selon son
futur directeur
le tout c'est julie des jeunes la
couleur c'est celle d'aujourd'hui
l'ambition c'est de créer un lien entre
le public jeune et nous mêmes une chaîne
musicale
c'est une chaîne qui ne rentrent pas en
concurrence avec tf1 antenne de houla 5
c'est une chaîne qui répond à des
préoccupations à des besoins à des idées
à des halles enthousiasme du public
johnny 150 films par an au temple dans
le service public avec les mêmes
contraintes sur les délais de diffusion
50% de films français christian fechner
de la gaumont codirigera la cie et puis
la publicité bien sûr même liberté que
sur l'a5 d'interrompre les programmes
peu de ceci sonne âge c'est promis mais
pour une chaîne gratuite
il faut de la pub 300 millions de francs
de budget pour démarrer sans doute plus
ensuite 18 ans de concession
indemnisation de l'état en cas de
modification du paysage audiovisuel
comme pour la fin grâce aux efforts de
tdf 8 millions de personnes à paris et
dans les grandes villes de province
recevront l'a6 à la mi-février 18
millions à la fin d'année si tout va
bien d'ici là le gouvernement a donc
choisi il était en présence de trois
projets parmi lesquels le dossier
présenté par l'ugc lagence de jacques
séguéla
d'autre part la sellette et c'est à dire
la maison-mère de rtl georges fillioud
expliqué tout à l'heure les raisons de
ce choix
du côté de la clt projets des maires de
rtl est un problème parce que l'insulté
consentait à être minoritaires mais n'a
pas indiqué dans ses propositions
officielles quels étaient ces mêmes
partenaires financiers et d'autre part
la ciel tu es ne voulait être le seul
opérateur en somme je voulais le patron
de la chaîne or une règle que nous
étions posés au départ était de dire que
le concessionnaire l opérateur d'une
télévision nationale et reviennent en
france devait être de nationalité
française
alors les deux autres projets celui
baptisé tv
d'un côté et publicis beaumont de
l'autre et être assez proches l'un de
l'autre et je peux vous dire que j'ai
espéré leur rapprochement j'aime faire
d'effort pour qu'une fusion soit
possible qui nous simplifier les choses
ça permettait de mettre en commun les
moyens des gens et des autres finalement
les deux promoteurs ont longuement
discuté mais n'ont pas réussi à
s'entendre donc il a bien fallu choisir
oui tout comme la cinquième chaîne
confié monsieur seydoux d'allos coni le
choix du gouvernement pour cette
nouvelle chaîne pour cette sixième
chaîne suscite des réactions très
hostiles de l'opposition je vous propose
d'écouter charles pasqua pour le rpr et
alain madelin pour lui dès leur réaction
dans cette affaire comme dans la sphère
précédentes les conditions élémentaires
qui doit permettre de faire appel à la
libre concurrence ne sont pas respectées
si le gouvernement actuel au mépris de
toute logique et au mépris des règles
élémentaires de la démocratie veut
utiliser les deux mois qui lui restent
pour brader à ses propres amis le
patrimoine audiovisuel des faut que les
choses soient claires nous remettrons
tout cela en cause lorsque nous
arriverons à faire on donne on brade la
sixième chaîne de télévision un groupe
constitué autour d'un autre frère ces
deux je dirais que véritablement c'est
un scandale pour la morale politique à
quelques semaines des élections de faire
cette pseudo privatisations alors moi je
dis oui à la cinquième chaîne de
télévision oui à la sixième chaîne wii
aux chaînes de télévision privées
oui à la loi du marché mais non à la loi
des copains non à la loi des frères
dalton de l'audiovisuel socialiste la
mort du peintre lorgeoux il avait 77 ans
était toujours affirmée comme un
partisan acharné du figuratif contre
l'art abstrait anticonformiste toute une
partie de son oeuvre apparaît comme un
cri contre l'injustice ses dernières
toiles étaient d'ailleurs consacré au
sida vue vous allez le voir comme un
facteur dépôt vente
voilà en exil volontaire depuis plus de
10 ans dans sa maison de saint denis sur
loire une maison dont les murs lutte eu
lieu
valais lorgeoux était resté un peintre
engagé au trait aux couleurs
volontairement agressive une conception
très figuratives de la peinture qui on
faisait l'adversaire de l'art abstrait
mais aussi de l'impressionnisme les
impressionnistes sont les grands
malfaiteurs de la peinture c'est les
gens c'est qu'ils ont fait de la
peinture pour les bourgeois pour décorer
leur petit appartement
or la peinture est parfaite pour ça la
peinture et les fêtes pour dire quelque
chose pour exprimer des idées
et puis en un temps pour que plastic man
elle ne donne une force une un esprit à
une époque lorgeoux une oeuvre consacrée
à des sujets forts comme les atrocités
de la guerre d'espagne des thèmes de
tous les jours le conducteur de
locomotive est toujours l'exubérance de
la couleur considéré comme puisque la
forme chez leurs jours ce sont ses
couleurs c'est certainement le plus
grand coloriste de ce siècle
si vous venez et est l'égal d'un matisse
peut-être le dépasse t il si vous voulez
alors on a parfois dit qu' il avait un
petit peu copié que c'est toi le
rappeler picasso par exemple faut dire
que lorgeoux copier picasso c'est une
erreur fondamentale c'est quelqu'un qui
ne connaît pas la date de leur jeu qui
peut dire ça leurs jours et et l'orge
pour sa dernière exposition ce mois ci à
paris lorgeoux était resté fidèle à sa
conception de la peinture emprise sur
l'actualité des toiles consacrées au
sida et l'actualité c'est peut-être
aussi aujourd'hui lily passion une heure
et demie de spectacle qui met face à
face barbara depardieu c'est un conte
musical pensé écrit conçu par la
chanteuse qui raconte l'histoire d'amour
d'une femme en noir vous l'avez compris
et d'un assassin nicole denis langlois a
assisté hier soir à la première de cette
représentation
elles chantent ils tuent ils s'aiment et
pour ce couple de passion ils sont tous
venus au rendez-vous des ministres en
place et les gens du métier des amis
et puis elisabeth émue pour gérard
vivant entendre une dernière fois la
descente chaud alors
landais
tant mieux contre une fois pour une fois
a fait montre à lire qui croyez moi ma
mission data fin moi j'avais 15 ans je
suivais ma plus belle histoire d'amour
et bout une déclaration d'amour que
barbara adresse au public
retrouvez un pari périlleux gagner ce
soir est commencé depuis longtemps
depuis cinq ans
c'est ce travail effacer la complicité
de barbara fc sète a séduite et cette
rigueur contrainte
en tout les fans de tous les instants
qui fait que ce qu'on existe maintenant
c'est magique
remy nice ce soir
non
la passion pour
voilà la qualité de ce mardi c'est aussi
la météo maintenant avec alain
gillot-pétré et que l'on m'a qu'on
puisse dire c'est que le ciel a la
bougeotte avec beaucoup de vent beaucoup
de pluie regardez la photo satellite
voici voici une perturbation qui a
abordé la bretagne cet après midi qui va
traverser la moitié nord ouest du pays
cette nuit avec beaucoup de vent de sud
ouest assez fort vraiment et qui demain
se trouvera au sud est
rejoignant cette autre perturbation qui
est venu d'espagne les deux vont
s'empiler ça nous donnera comme prévu
depuis plusieurs jours un train est très
mauvais temps regarder la mer de nuages
qui nous arrive alors la carte
évidemment et sinistre beaucoup de
nuages des pyrénées en milieu de journée
des pyrénées au massif central au
nord-est à la corse avec de la neige de
la pluie des vents forts de sud ouest
hippiques derrière et bien sûr le nord
ouest comme vous le constatez aussi
temps très nuageux avec des vents forts
de nord-ouest de cette fois de la pluie
de la grêle et quelques petites
éclaircies
quand même côté température ça ne te
rabaisse évidemment puisque cela vient
du nord-ouest de 3 à 6 degrés sur la
moitié nord 4 à paris et de 3 à 12
degrés seulement sur la moitié sud
qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est l'hiver
demain ce sera le mercredi 29 janvier le
soleil se lèvera paris à 8h27 ici que je
réalise tout cas rendu à 9,3 2008 de
soleil en plus bonne fête à tous les
gildas et en plus il fera 4 degrés à
poligny là je vous rappelle les
principales informations de ce journal
d'abord le drame de la navette
challenger l'engin a explosé un peu
moins d'une minute 43 secondes
exactement après son décollage
il y avait sept astronautes à bord n'y a
pas de survivant le président américain
reagan va faire tout à l'heure une
déclaration prix et puis seconde
information le coup d'envoi officiel de
la sixième chaîne
elle est confiée au groupe phr étaient
réunis gaumont publicis l' agence de
publicité gilbert gross et la radio
privée énergie dont informations et
bernard pradines au d'autres précisions
environs de 23 heures 40 pourquoi à
demain